hallo mein name ist wo kann ich bin dumm
deswegen sage ich euch jetzt 20 fakten
bei meiner dummheit wer dachte ich
schauspieler können unendlich viele
sprachen sprechen weil die filme ja
immer unendlich viele sprachen übersetzt
werden ich vollidiot ich hab mir
letztens einen bluterguss am daumen
zugezogen als ich den bluterguss an
rausschneiden wollte als herausgewachsen
ist habe ich mir beim ausschneiden
wieder bluterguss zugezogen
ich weiß noch immer nicht wie das wort
ausgesprochen wird oder werbe ich weiß
es nicht hält sich aus amerika wieder
kamen habe ich die ersten paar stunden
nicht die zeit umgestellt und hatte
totale probleme irgendwie klar zu kommen
dann ist es mir aufgefallen ich habe mir
damals nur kollege bestellt allerdings
hatte ich die ganze zeit falsch bestimmt
bis vor ein paar wochen ein kumpel
vorbei kam der gitarrist und damit an
gezeigt hat dass man die ukulele an das
stimmt als ich sie gestimmt habe das ist
bestimmt der hauptgrund warum ich damit
die ganze zeit nicht richtig spielen
konnte atemlos als ich klein war ich
immer angst vor dem quad von meinem
onkel weil ich dachte dass es sich in
der nacht zu einem transformer
verwandeln würde immer wenn ich mir die
zähne putze juckt meine nase von innen
ich weiß nicht warum ich habe auch schon
gegoogelt woran das liegen könnte aber
meine nase juckt von innen wenn ich mir
die zähne putzen als ich in new york
angekommen war ich so müde dass ich
einfach in dem taxifahrer gesagt habe er
solle mich einfach zum hotel bringen
dann bin ich im taxi eingeschlafen war
letztendlich glaube ich zwei stunden im
taxi und der typ hat mich voll verarscht
und mir nachher 136 dollar dafür
abgenommen ich wollte mal von bielefeld
nach frankfurt am main fahren allerdings
habe ich im stress ins navi irgendwie
frankfurt an der oder ein gegeben und
bin dann die ersten 50 kilometern den
osten gefahren anstatt in den süden ich
spaß ich bin 19 jahre alt und kann auch
immer nicht meine eigenen klamotten
waschen haye eine kurze zusatz kleiner
einschub la hier in dem video weil ich
euch kurz was sagen muss und zwar findet
am 19 september um 17 uhr ein live event
im ewerk statt in köln 19 september 16
uhr und zwar von live event wo ich mit
lp mit cap mit krankhafter mit hardy mit
lukas der rapper und vielleicht noch ein
paar andere youtuber auf der bühne stehe
und ihr könnt da hinkommen und mit und
zocken und da könnt ihr auch mit auf die
bühne und erich wir geben auch
autogramme und es gibt
mit pullis und t-shirts und so weiter
ich habe euch einfach mal ein link in
die beschreibung gepackt der highstakes
inc.com von crafter dort irgendwo in der
beschreibung könnt ihr einfach mal drauf
klicken wenn interessiert seid dorthin
zu kommen da stehen noch weitere
informationen dazu dass wolltest du ihm
kurz sagen weil ich immer gefragt werde
ob ich auf der you messe bin oder auf
der gamescom weil ich werde bei beiden
nicht sein bei dem video das weiß ich
noch nicht genau aber da bin ich auf
jeden fall und da könnt ihr auf jeden
fall gerne vorbeischauen wenn ihr
möchtet ich habe zwar einen imac von
apple allerdings nutzt sich darauf auch
teilweise windows einfach weil ich auf
windows aufnehme es nur windows die
ganzen programme gibt die ich zum
aufnehmen nutze
allerdings nutze ich hauptsächlich immer
noch apple für präsentationen und
musikhören und chillen und arbeiten und
und fotos machen und was weiß ich alles
weil ich apple einfach viel besser finde
ich finde aber cool dass man bei apple
produkten die möglichkeit hat eine
windows partition darauf zu spielen bei
windows hat man das ganze nicht in bezug
auf apple
und deswegen bin ich damit auch völlig
zufrieden ich habe mir mal drei jacken
in den größen s m und l bestellt nur um
herauszufinden welche größe ich jetzt
endlich brauchen dann wollte ich halt
die anderen beiden zurücksenden die mir
zu groß zu klein waren
allerdings habe ich letztendlich alle
drei zurück gesendet weil jack einfach
scheiße außer ich kann nicht kochen bzw
nur reis spaghetti quark münchen gemüse
unseren leichten schals halt ich habe
mir vor zwei wochen eine packung post
gekauft bei der mir heute beim aufwachen
aufgefallen ist dass sie schon längst
wieder abgelaufen ist ich habe in einer
klausur mal eine drei plus bekommen
trotz dessen nicht die kompletten
aufgaben auf der rückseite nicht gesehen
habe und dementsprechend nicht
bearbeitet habe ich besitze drei
sonnenbrillen etui hüllen hier ich kann
ihr euch mal zeigen dir diese drei
besitzt sich aber die die und die aber
nur in dieser hier ist eine sonnenbrille
drin weil die anderen beiden
sonnenbrillen habe ich bei den letzten
beiden holy festivals verloren das hier
ist auch noch die sonne ohne brille die
ich find ich weiß nicht wie es die kugel
aber irgendwie ist das auch so mit
diesen bügeln das erinnert mich immer so
an seine alte leute sonnenbrille aber
durch die sonnenbrille sieht alles so
schön aus wenn ich das mal anschaut
sieht schon schon sehr schön oder nein
ok dann lasst mir dass ich nutze noch
immer fremd oder city zum aufnehmen
obwohl mittlerweile nahezu jeder gaming
youtuber schon auf obs umgestiegen ist
ich denke immer nur so never change a
running system das läuft bei mir und ich
werde wahrscheinlich in zehn jahren
benutzen wenn ich dann noch youtube
machen werde ich habe mir vor circa
einem jahr eine wii plus gekauft
allerdings bisher circa vier mal
gespielt oder 50 wenn's hochkommt ich
bin heute morgen in den supermarkt
gelaufen und dann einfach wieder zu
meiner wohnung gestellt weil ich
überhaupt total vergessen hatte was ich
überhaupt einen supermarkt wollte
spreche gerade mit einer kamera
eigentlich ist das in einer gewissen
form schon dumm
das war es mit diesem video über meine
dummheit 20 fakten über mich und meine
dummen eigenschaften wenn es euch
gefallen hat will ich nicht über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr mehr von
solchen fakten sheard videos haben wollt
dann schreibt sie meine kommentare über
was ihnen sonst noch was im blatt
schreibt mir einfach unten rein aber
welches themengebiet ich euch sonst noch
irgendwas über mich erzählen soll sonst
findet und in der beschreibung auf den
link stakes link wo ihr ticket kaufen
bestellen reservieren können für das
play-off games event am 19 september um
17 uhr im e-werk und sonst würde ich
sagen sehen uns im nächsten video wieder
ich sehe ich gerade ich muss unbedingt
mal wieder zum friseur mittlerweile
schon so lange haare wie elvis alter wie
gehen mir hier vorne schon bis zur nase
das kann auch nicht sein ich muss ich
muss ich glaube ich geht zum friseur
jazz